Francis zanu looked fantastic from every
aspect I had him win that fight I
watched it again this morning you could
easily give him four to five rounds plus
you give him the 108 round for the
knockdown did Tyson do his boxing thing
land some Jabs and stay active towards
the later rounds yep but overall France
has won that fight and I I I tweet this
out you're back crazy if you think the
boxing world who hates MMA if you think
those old school dinosaur judges were
going to give Francis ganu that fight VI
decision there's not a chance remember
what goes into this in December Tyson is
supposed to fight usyk in that same
Arena probably with the same judges do
you really think that they would give a
MMA guy with zero boxing experience a
decision win over Tyson Fury the
greatest heavyweight of all time the
lineage Champion not a CH there is not a
more corrupt sport on this planet than
boxing